marvel fans i am here with zendaya mj
herself how are you i'm good how are you
i'm doing pretty great so i have a
couple questions this is the biggest
spider-man film yet and there's a lot of
stunts how did it feel to be web
slinging and flying high
oh man it was so much fun i love being
able to do that stuff especially because
we feel incredibly safe we have an
amazing stunt coordinator and um
you just you just get to have fun i i'm
not afraid of heights in that way so i
feel really good about it yeah well i
can't wait to see how has mj changed
since we last seen her um i think she's
just opening up more i think now that
she has
has peter in her life and and someone
and ned of obviously people who feel
that love her for who she is i think
she's able to slightly just open up a
little bit more and maybe even be a
little bit more positive because usually
she's like the nihilistic friend right
she's the one that's always looking at
things glass half empty so it's nice to
see that side of her
[Music]
you